الوضع الطبي هنا في عموم شمال غرب سوريا
ودعني اتحدث هنا في مشفى الشفاء يعني من
ناحيه الاجهزه الطبيه هناك
عجز في موضوع الاجهزه الطبيه وخصوصا في
موضوع الاجهزه المتعلقه بامراض الكلى وهذا
يعني وهذا الاختصاص يعني
هو الاكثر
طلبا هنا بعد حادثه الزلزال الذي ضربت
المنطقه خصوصا لمصابين متلازمه الهرس طبعا
هناك عجز في موضوع الاجهزه اما بالنسبه
لعمل المنظمات
المنظمات تاتي الى الى المشافي تقدم بعض
الهدايا للاطفال الهدايا
العينيه او الهدايا الرمزيه للاطفال اما
من الناحيه الطبيه فهناك عجز في الحقيقه
من ناحيه الاجهزه الطبيه هناك مناشدات
تطلق من شمال غرب سوريا لا يزال الاطباء
هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
المناشدات للخارج بالاسراع بادخال الاجهزه
الطبيه لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه